beschreiben montag dem 24
januar 2022 stehen unseren
und heute beginnen endlich die ohne
arbeit für unser neues büro
wir fangen damit an wendiger
reinzuziehen da muss gespachtelt
geschliffen gemalert werden als erstes
müssen wir natürlich die wände ziehen
wir lernen also was es alles braucht um
wände zu erschaffen wo man auch keine
wände sind mit neue grundstruktur im
büro entstehen kann so wie wir uns das
vorstellen das ganze war ich natürlich
nicht alleine sondern mit
professioneller unterstützung grund zum
einen toben
und zum anderen weniger professioneller
unterstützung von max und ganz vielen
helfern die gleich noch dazu kommen
werden du bist link ist ganz oben in der
video beschreibung er wird uns zeigen
wie das alles funktioniert aber das
ganze geht natürlich nicht ohne material
sowie kannst und sagen das sind die
ersten step
die wende
dabei wird wir gucken können wo genau
die wir nicht sehen wie wir die
einstellung von dem virus machen und
dann müssen natürlich erst material
besorgen bevor wir anfangen können und
dann müssen wir das grundstück bauen
damit wir dann die trockenbau
plattengrenzen können denn es kommt ein
professionelles lasergerät gekauft
ich dachte du wirst du darüber lachen
und
youtube
ich bin quasi vor vielen dank
krass ist wirklich ein zweiter auf
youtube zu haben also der welt sprechen
dieser maxime fest
max steht schon in seiner kirche leo du
kannst hier mal um ihn herum
neuenkirchen
[Musik]
ich bin der könig im scheiße labern wir
auf das stell verbau stelle und du ich
bin
ich bin ich
also tatsächlich stehen die
raumaufteilung jetzt will muss ein
bisschen dribbeln das ist nicht ganz wie
wir es geplant hatten einfach weil wir
jetzt im prozess gemerkt haben hey wir
brauchen da ein paar zentimeter wir
brauchen da ein bisschen weniger platz
das hier werden unsere räume bekommt das
büro der cutter hin hier sitzen max und
ich hier ist unser lager und hier vorne
ist unser streaming raums die küche ist
auch an gezeichnet das ist vermutlich
der größte raum den wir hier haben jetzt
fahren wir zum oberen alles was wir
brauchen dann heißt es als allererstes
ständer ziehen das werdet ihr aber
gleich alles sehen gefahren erst mal zum
obi und kaufen was wir brauchen
so baumaterialien für knapp zweieinhalb
tausend euro wir haben eine tür
rigipsplatten volt profile aller form
und farbe spachtelmasse wirklich alles
was das herz begehrt profile die zu
langen sind wir jetzt durch schneiden
müssen damit die dann noch ins auto
passen diese riesen karre wird gleich
voll sein und nicht zu vergessen das
ganze dem material was jetzt noch nicht
drin ist und man ist die karre folgen
dann geht's ab zurück nach köln
das ist wirklich bis auf den letzten
millimeter komplett voll auf den auf
haus bekommt ja den haben wir aufs haus
jetzt kann endlich die richtige arbeit
losgehen halben tag darauf verschwendet
den ganzen scheiß zu besorgen einzuladen
hin und her zu fahren weil das auch
alles jetzt nicht im aller nächsten
baumarkt verfügbar es ist aber alles
eingezeichnet jetzt kann es wirklich
losgehen außerdem außerdem gibt es gute
news die damit wir in allen räumen bei
tageslicht haben war gerade eben jemand
da der sich um glastüren für alle räume
kümmert max bitte gott sei dank sehr
gerne und zwar wird hierbei der küche
eine insgesamt drei mal zwei meter 80
große glasfront entstehen nämlich eine
glas flügeltür gefasst in einen rahmen
aus quadratischen fensterscheiben hier
drüben wird entsprechend auf 260 höher
also bündig waren aussparung der fenster
1 1 in der tür entstehen genauso wie in
anderen druck weiter gleich groß etwa
zwei meter 60 mal 90 zentimeter
so industrie lofts die schwarzen flecken
richtig
[Musik]
ich komme nicht alleine sondern mit der
lösung eines großen problems
dieses geräusch hören wir nicht die
ganze zeit denn wir haben ein großes
problem denn wir können im boden nicht
bohren was eigentlich essentiell dafür
ist um trockenbauwände hochzuziehen wir
haben eine fußbodenheizung was uns
aufgefallen ist nachdem wir die ersten
drei löcher gebohrt haben das ist
schlecht wir haben uns eine alternative
optionen überlegt beziehungsweise tobi
hat sie bei anderen kollegen erfragt und
die ist die american way wir müssen
kleben ich habe zwanzig mal diesen
stärksten kleber gekauft in dem finden
konnten es gibt keine andere möglichkeit
so bleibt der boden aber unbeschadet und
wir bohren definitiv nicht in die
fußbodenheizung jetzt geht es rein wir
machen erst die decke fertig und dann
geht's am boden weiter haben sie mir die
wendung
ein ganz unbeschriebenes blatt wenn ich
tatsächlich nicht einen dachboden habe
ich schon mal mit meinem vater
ausgekleidet ging es aber nicht darum
profile im rhein zu bekommen denn die
wand war schon da wir mussten da nur
rigipsplatten und dämmung einhämmern
aber ein bisschen habe ich in meinem
leben doch auch schon gearbeitet
ich danke ich werde gut darauf aufpassen
und mit den ehren
darf ich das nach außen machen am besten
ok
ok perfekt der erste stand auf dem song
zum besten mann sind hier alle zu einem
[Musik]
wir haben 20 55 damit haben wir
geschlagen 13 stunden hier jetzt
gearbeitet tag eins ist rum ich bin
richtig stolz ich finde es nicht gut
dass wir eine firma beauftragt haben
vielen dank an alle die geholfen haben
die kompletten stützen stehen morgen
heißt es wenn du verkleiden dämmen und
dann wirklich die richtigen räume mal
sehen aber dafür geschafft die vorarbeit
ist größtenteils gemacht jetzt heißt
schlafen morgen sie bereits geht es
weiter tag zwei tag nummer zwei wir
haben gestern unendlich viel geschafft
und ich berichte bilder sie jetzt sofort
weitergeht wir starten zu dritt haben
gerade die letzten querverstrebungen
hier über der eingangstür von der küche
gemacht und jetzt gehts tatsächlich an
den wirklichen trockenbau hier gibt's zu
schneiden rigips anbringen dann
irgendwann auch aber mit dem re gibt
werden wir erst mal genug zu tun haben
ganz kurz noch mal was aber gestern
alles geschafft zum einen haben wir die
küche komplett mit profilen ausgekleidet
also hier an der seite entsteht so ein
gang hier wird langfristig vermutlich
ein großer spiegel hängen dann eine
riesige front und ihr seht schon ein
riesiges loch am eingang des
küchenbereich gekommen so eine
loftartige riesige glastür ein das wird
ziemlich cool und der raum wurde die
umrisse des raumes lassen sich schon
erkennen und da bin ich sehr happy ich
drüber auf dieser seite sind sogar schon
die ersten wege platten zu sehen dass
sie wird dass katar büro hier vorne
kommt auch so eine glastür ein ziemlich
groß und vom tageslicht von hier mit
rein und das büro ist genauso große
umsatz nebendran wir haben allerdings
entdecken licht auch hier mit großer
türen können sogar schon mal ins büro
reingehen hier werden dann die beiden
schreibtische stehen klein aber fein
direkt nebendran großes lager hier wäre
so schäffer regale stehen und da werden
wir unser ganzes equipment lagern hier
kommen so eine kleine werkbank hin und
man kann man hier durchgehend einen
winzig kleinen streaming raum hier wird
an meinem setup stehen und hier werde
ich sitzen und das ist ziemlich nah es
tatsächlich funktioniert das mit dem
regel schneiden super easy man kann das
einfach mit dem cutter messer schneiden
all das und super viele andere sachen
hat tobi uns gezeigt und erklärt so dass
wir eigenständig arbeiten können also
checkt auf jeden fall den ersten link in
der video beschreibung applus tobi ein
bisschen liebe da und schaut euch an die
ihr selber auch trockenbauwände ziehen
und bearbeiten es macht eine menge laune
wirklich selber hand anzulegen und genau
das wollen wir jetzt auch wieder jetzt
heißt die platte fest schneiden und ihr
sind dem prozess in nattheim labs wir
machen jetzt die wende zu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich denke gerade in meinem büro das
voraussichtlich oder zumindest
vertraglich zugesichert den nächsten
fünf jahren hier drin zu sein das jetzt
selber zu bauen ist über drei macht
richtig laune haben schon gedämmt jetzt
kommen rigips rein im anderen zimmer
wird schon gespachtelt also der welt
schon hier die ganze jugend gemacht dass
wir schnellstmöglich anfangen können
zumal an beziehungsweise muss man
geschliffen werden und dann geht es
weiter aber ich finde es gut wir sind
seit zwei tagen hier ballern und wir
machen denke ich fortschritte
tatkräftige unterstützung von den leuten
in unserem macht es sich lohnt
[Musik]
19.30 das bedeutet wir sind wieder seit
zwölf stunden am werkeln und wir hinter
mir schon seht es kommen so langsam
wirklich zusammen die räume stehen jetzt
nicht nur die träger sondern tatsächlich
wirklich komplette wende kommt einmal
mit
[Musik]
ist sogar schon verspachtelt das könnte
hier sind in den anderen räumen hängen
alle regatten zumindest teilweise im
maxxim einem büro das ist quasi ready da
wurde angefangen so ein bisschen zu
spachteln und hier vorne im lager und
der streaming raum hängt auch soweit
alles werden heute abend noch die küche
in angriff nehmen so dass morgen dann an
tag 3 alle wände wirklich final stehen
und es nur noch gespachtelt und
geschliffen und gemacht nur noch
gespachtelt geschliffen und gemalert
werden und ich freue mich sehr scheinbar
sieht so aus als könnten wir innerhalb
der nächsten fünf tage oder drei tage
hier wirklich anfangen sachen report zu
ziehen dann geht es noch einmal darum
dass wir wirklich die ganze gestaltung
von dem band machen das wird dann erst
in ein paar wochen passieren aber die
raumaufteilung steht es ist gemalert und
es ist quasi bezugsfertig da muss nur
noch gestaltet und eingerichtet werden
richtig krass was man in zwei tagen mit
vernünftiger anleitung von profilen dank
hinbekommt jetzt noch mal drei stunden
angriff und dann geht es morgen weiter
mit dem fall
[Musik]
ok ende von tag nummer drei es ist
wirklich eine absolute tortur wir sind
jeden tag zwölf bis 14 stunden hier aber
es geht tatsächlich voran der raum der
kader ist komplett fertig gespachtelt
wir haben so sehr durch gezogen dass
hier
auch schon zweifach gespachtelt sind
insgesamt braucht mit drei schichten
morgen muss das alles noch geschliffen
und dann gemalt werden mal sehen ob wir
das schaffen denn wir haben eigentlich
nur noch morgen zeit und wenn wir uns
einmal noch umdrehen abseits des ganzen
träschs des bieres und des fahrrads was
da an der seite steht die komplette
küche jetzt verkleidet alles ist fertig
das muss eben noch komplett gespachtelt
werden innen wie außen aber es ist alles
gedämmt im prinzip stehen alle räume wir
haben unendlich viel geschafft im
prinzip das alles mit vier oder fünf
leuten die vorher keinen plan hat wie
das alles funktioniert warum geht's
weiter der finale tag in dem sich
entscheidet ob wir es schaffen
kammer 4 wir sind immer noch hier und
getriebe einer der helfenden hände
wollte was ich das so sage das habe ich
getan ich bin unfassbar stolz wie weit
wir gekommen sind wir berichten live von
der baustelle halbe stunde vor upload
wir sind so viel am arbeiten und es
passiert so viel dass wir das jetzt gar
nicht mehr mit ihnen dieses video packen
sondern dass im nächsten video kommt
möglicherweise geht es auch im nächsten
video schon um den streaming raum um
vergebung ich werde dieses gesamte
projekt weiter auf dem kanal begleiten
wenn ihr das nicht verpassen wollte
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
was dem video gerne den like da und hier
noch mal wirklich zum schluss ein
riesenschock an alle handwerker unter
euch oder auch sonstwo ich finde das
sehr beeindruckend vielen vielen dank an
tobi der gerade parallel da auch sein
video fordert schaut er sofort rein wenn
ich ihr fertig seid da gibt es wirklich
noch mal einen deutlich größeren
einblick da habe ich noch viel mehr
moderiert mit tobi gemeinsam toni zeigt
wie das alles funktioniert riesenstau
dort an jeden handwerker das übelste was
ihr macht und vielleicht komme ich ja
mit anderen handwerkern auch noch mal in
kontakt weil ich übels bock hab das zu
lernen wir sehen uns am sonntag wieder
rolex trader finale dass wir richtig
krass was guten tag